on a été approché par monsieur laine qui
est le patois de dominique strauss kahn
on nous a apporté beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de preuve de sérieux et c'est
aussi bien au travers des valeurs des
actions au travers du capital de
puisqu'il s'agissait de rentrer au
capital de
cette banque d'affaires
et lescar on a vérifié on a vérifié
avant d'investir bien entendu on a
vérifié
les dires de
retirer l'aide et comme s'avérait
effectivement comme étant des la vérité
donc on a effectivement
on est des gens relativement simple il
s'avère que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
une vie professionnelle très
intéressante vous faisiez mois là
en fait j'ai travaillé très tôt dans
l'informatique puisqu'elle va je suis
maintenant à la retraite et jusque pour
pour apporter une petite image
je travaille dans une société qui
s'appelait digital equipment qui à
l'époque était le numéro deux mondial de
l'informatique d'accord et mon service
s'est occupé de l'arrivée des premiers
pc dans le monde d'accord
je vous laisse imaginer bien serait ce
que ça veut dire bien sûr dont vous avez
peut être une très belle somme de côté
un million cent quarante mille euros
toutes vos économies et là on vous dit
de déplacés c'est ça c'est le bras droit
de dsk qui m'a alors les placer dans sa
bande c'est ça voilà tout à fait
l'objectif c'était de les placer dans le
capital de l'entreprise
avec on avait eu une garantie écrite
bien entendu qui consistait à dire que
si on voulait ressortir de ce capital
nous pouvait le faire néanmoins avec un
préavis d'une quinzaine de jours
d'accord sachant qu'on rentrait avec un
prix qui étaient inférieures bien
inférieur à celui du marché alors vous
avez essayé de sortir formation vous
avez essayé de sortir avant votre argent
c'est ça va on a mais on n'a même pas
réussi à rentrer enfin ça à avoir une
journée puisque en fait le jour où le
virement bancaire a été fait vers le
comté lescar le lendemain matin toute la
rue tout l'argent a disparu
en est rendu compte tout de suite alors
s'en est pas rendu compte tout de suite
parce que maintenant attendu les
mouvements bancaires comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer prennent un petit peu de
temps mais très très vite quand on a
commencé à avoir des appels télé achat
chercher à avoir des appels
téléphoniques que ce soit sur ou au
niveau du conseil d'administration de
l'esca etc
plus personne ne répondait on avait plus
d'interlocuteur il y avait plus personne
n'y avait plus rien voilà vous avez vous
avez eue dsk lui-même au téléphone avant
de mettre l'argent c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit oui tout à fait tout à fait c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné on avait dans
un des bureaux de cherrie de la haine il
a fait le notaire de
l'esca qui était qui était à côté de
nous une accord aussi papier
effectivement
dsk passé un petit coup de fil pour nous
féliciter on va dire
d'être entré dans
le capital de son entreprise et donc
c'est un million deux cent quarante
mille euros envolés
son parti une petite anecdote qui est
très intéressante et qui dénote bien le
côté très particulier de monsieur
dominique strauss kahn
c'est qu'on devait faire le virement sur
une certaines banques et la veille du
virement on nous a demandé de faire le
virement sur une autre banque dans un
autre pays en l'occurrence en suisse
d'accord donc sur un compte récemment
ouvert de la société sk qui avait ouvert
deux jours plus tôt
on n'a pas
imaginé mois que ce soit par rapport à
ça donc sauf que après on a su pourquoi
ça avait été fait comme ça il faut
savoir le mans parce que dsk avait une
amie à qui il devait beaucoup d'argent
et cette amie elle avait un compte dans
cette banque la et donc ça permettait de
faire un virement de contact d'une façon
extrêmement rapide